Speaker 1: A series of text messages that were
provided by Mark Meadows. Donald Trump's former
chief of staff are absolutely chilling in
the complete and total disregard for the
constitution and for our elections that they
expose, particularly from some Republican
members of Congress, including one guy, Ralph
Norman, who said that he wanted Donald Trump to
declare martial law. That's Emma R s h a l l,
which we'll get to. This is really horrifying
stuff. Republican congressman wanted Trump to
invoke, quote, martial law to stay in office
based on some leaked texts. Mark Meadows texted
with 34 different lawmakers about overturning
the 2020 election, including a confused Ralph
Norman Talking Points memo has some of the most
stunning messages. And at the top of that list
is this message we're putting up on the screen
from Ralph Norman, who wrote to Mark Meadows,
quote, Mark, in seeing what's happening so
quickly and reading about the Dominion lawsuits,
attempting to stop any meaningful investigation,
we are at a point of no return in saving our
republic. Our last hope is invoking martial
law. Misspelled. Please urge President to do so
clearly. Norman, a fan of the rapper Eminem, whose
real name is Marshall Mathers, and that's what he
meant by martial law. He thought some of the songs
might be useful. These are not the actions of a
small government constitutionalist conservative,
are they? Hey, even though we lost and the
Constitution says Biden now gets to be president,
let's try to invoke and use the military to keep
us in power. This was an attempt at a coup, which
he said, let's try and do it. And importantly,
this text message was sent on January 17th, 2021.
Think about what that means. It means that after
seeing everything that happened on January 6th,
Ralph Norman thought, Give me some more of that
stuff. We need more of that. The insurrection.
I'd like to order another one. Please bring me
another one on the rocks. So what is our takeaway?
And we'll post the links. There's a lot of other
text messages that you can look at. For example,
there's like a Jason Miller text message. F
Why? I asked Ali Pardo from our press shop to
get in touch with Mo Brooks since he seems to
be the ringleader leader on January 6th. They
say they will have as many as 50 members on board
on January six, but we won't have a list of names
until Sunday or Monday. Anyway. The point here is
they were all planning. They were all involved.
It's it's even more horrifying than we believed.
And I encourage you to look at and read through
the text messages. But what's the takeaway? The
takeaway is this is not the last time they're
going to try this. They're going to be back.
There was way more support for this than we might
have thought or hoped, number one. Number two,
the recent Marjorie Taylor GREENE clip that we
looked at yesterday where she said, you know,
if I had been in charge of the insurrection,
I would have been armed and we would have won
means that they see what happened on January
6th as a loss, not because there were crimes
committed, not because people got arrested.
They see January 6th as a loss because they
didn't succeed in stealing the election.
And getting the guy who didn't win in the Oval
Office. So they're clearly going to try again.
They failed. Their execution was horrible. But it
was clearly much closer than it ever should have
been to being something that happened and could
have been their definition of success. There's no
doubt what they wanted. It's not going to be the
last time. Next time, the concern is, will they
have all of the players in place? Will they better
know where it could be hung up and be prepared to
deal with that? Will they have stronger cover
from courts after more v harper will they have
a legal framework to ignore elections? So this is
a red alert moment. One of the things I always try
to do on this show is not to be hyperbolic and to
catastrophize, but this is really worse than we've
probably acknowledged. And we've acknowledged
that it is pretty damn bad. So check out the
text messages, will publish the links. They're
all there. And by the way, I haven't looked
through all of them. It's thousands of messages.
You may find things that are as or even more
concerning than the martial law comment from Ralph
Norman. Let me know if you do find those things